Porton Down is one of the most secretive
military establishments in the UK it is
the location of the defense Science and
Technology laboratories hidden away on
Salisbury Plain for decades this place
was the source of conspiracy theories
about strange goings-on today porting
down as the center of research into
chemical and biological weapons at the
end of this corridor in a building that
I'm not allowed to name is a laboratory
where scientists are working on the
latest chemical repellent for security
reasons we can only call the scientists
here by their first names in the
laboratory
kourin shows me how a plasma that has
been developed can stop deadly chemical
liquids from soaking into clothing once
been coated ones just as it came out the
packet if I put a droplet of this dyed
water on yes this this could be it could
be a solvent or a petrol or something so
that's absorb straightening yeah and if
I do the same thing on this treated
piece Porton Down was built during World
War one when German forces started
gassing British soldiers this was the
original headquarters it is the only
building on the site that we are allowed
to film during the Cold War when the
threat of gas attack was considered high
it was here that scientists tried to
keep up with their Russian counterparts
the black Bell respirator year this was
written first response to the use of
chlorine back in 1915 lives horror to
where it's essentially cotton waste
material so it with various chemicals
chlorine you'd sight around you around
you around your mouth and hope for the
best 100 years on technology has moved
on thankfully because I am being allowed
to test out the latest protective
equipment the respirator has to fit
perfectly so gas doesn't seep through
the seals I also have to put on a
chemical suit in rubber gloves on my
back
I'm carrying equipment that feeds live
data to an analyst monitoring how
effectively my mask is working the
chamber has been filled with a gas for
this test by running and jumping I'm
putting a mask under stress to see if
the seal is whole these might be
controlled conditions in the Wiltjer
countryside but this is where the
mistakes have to be sorted out if
mistakes occur when the masks have been
worn for real it could be deadly oh that
was hot how did I do good people betray
see you can see that you exercise you do
just that
most of the time you get in just over
one one or two particles in the
respirator so pretty Gary good song yeah
what you're looking for Porton Down also
works with police forces in the UK to
develop equipment in case of a chemical
or biological terror attack on the
streets of Britain the range of threats
that we face in terms of their
complexity is probably quite broad I
think it's fair to say that if if you
look at the press and you watch the news
then you can see that it's been a very
unstable world for the past few years
events in Syria and the Middle East have
clearly been shown that chemical weapons
are as relevant today as they were a
hundred years ago in the First World War
in recent years Islamic state has
launched gas attacks on Kurdish soldiers
in Iraq and President Assad has used
chemical weapons against his own people
Europe's intelligence agencies believed
that terrorist groups have ambitions to
carry out something similar on a Western
capital
port and downs work might be in secret
but if the terrorists ever succeed it
will come into its own Alastair bungles
Sky News
you